classical State corresponding to the row of that entry and one classical State corresponding to the column of that
entry for the diagonal entries those two classical states are the same state and that's why the diagonal entries are
special and one way we can interpret the diagonal entries is that they're probabilities and specifically there are
the probabilities that the corresponding classical state would appear if we were to perform a standard basis measurement
on the system whose Quantum State we're describing for the the off diagonal entries on the other hand we have one classical State corresponding to the row
of that entry and a different classical State corresponding to the column of that entry and very informally speaking
these entries describe the degree to which these two classical states are in Quantum superp position as well as the
relative phase between them that may make more sense as the lesson continues on and we look more
closely at some specific examples and the details may not be clear at this point but please don't let that bother
you this is quite informal and it's just meant to be an intuitive idea to keep in the back of your
mind next we'll take a look at the connection between density matrices and Quantum State vectors which are column
vectors having ukan Norm equal to one just to recall the mathematical definition supposing that we have a
Quantum State Vector s that represents the state of some particular system the density Matrix that represents the same
Quantum state is given by Ki times brasai as is shown here on the screen to be clear about this the indices of Sai
correspond in some way to the classical States of Whatever system we're talking about and that's going to be precisely the same correspondence we have between
the rows and Columns of our density Matrix and the classical states of the system if we imagine that there are n
classical states of the system and we think about column and row vectors as matrices then Ki is an N by one Matrix
and Brasi is a 1 byn Matrix so when we perform the multiplication we get an N byn
Matrix this will always be a positive semi-definite Matrix just by its form in fact and it will also have Trace equal
to one by virtue of the fact that s is a unit vector and we'll see that in more detail
shortly Quantum states that are represented by density matrices of this form are called Pure
States here are a few examples first let's consider this state
right here which is kind of like a plus State except that the entry corresponding to the classical State one is
imaginary if we compute the conjugate transpose we'll pick up a minus sign because the complex conjugate of I is
minus I and if we do the multiplication we'll get the Matrix that's shown here on the screen it's heran as we can
immediately see just by looking at it and it happens to have one ion value equal to one and one ion value equal to
zero so it's positive semi-definite and it Trace is equal to one so it is a density Matrix as
expected we can compute the density matrices corresponding to the standard basis and the plus minus bases in a similar way and those density matrices
are shown here and here's one more example of a Quantum State Vector it happened to
appear way back in the first lesson of the series and if we compute the conjugate transpose and then multiply
we'll get the density Matrix that's shown here once again it's herian and has
Trace equal to one and if you compute the IG values you'll find that again it has one IG value equal to one and one
igen value equal to zero and by the way that's a common characteristic of All Pure States they always have one I value
equal to one and the rest of the IG values are all zero in general for a completely arbitrary Quantum State
Vector s with any number of entries if we multiply Ki to brasai we'll obtain a
density Matrix that looks like this notice in particular that the diagonal entries are always one of the
entries of s multiplied to its own complex conjugate which we can alternatively Express as the absolute value squared of that entry and this is
one way to see that the trace will always be equal to one it's also consistent with the remark I made earlier in the lesson about the
diagonal entries of a density Matrix telling us what the probabilities would be to see each possible classical state
if we were to perform a standard basis measurement and one final remark there
is no issue concerning Global phases for density matrices two Quantum states are identical if and only if their density
matrices are equal in particular suppose that we have two Quantum State vectors s and fi that
are equ equalent up to a global phase which means that we can express one of them F let's say as the other one times
some complex number on the unit circle if we compute the density Matrix representation of fi then what we'll
find is that the global phase Factor gets multiplied by its own complex conjugate and that gives us one so it
effectively disappears and we're left with exactly the same density Matrix that we get from s so that's kind of a
nice little bonus and more generally there's no issue concerning equivalence up to Global phases at all when we're
working with density matrices that's just basically a degeneracy that exists when we use quantum State vectors rather
than density matrices to represent Quantum states density matrices possess a key property which is that convex
combinations of density matrices represent probabilistic or random selections of quantum
States another way of saying that is that density matrices can be averaged together in a meaningful way which is
not something that we can do with Quantum State vectors to explain this in more detail let's start with the situation in which
we have two density matrices row and sigma that represent Quantum states of some system let's imagine that the
system is prepared in the state row with probability P for some choice of P between zero and one and otherwise the
system is prepared in the state Sigma for example maybe p is 1/2 so we
we might imagine that someone flips a Fair coin and if it's heads they perform some process that leaves the system in
the state row and otherwise if the coin comes up taals they perform a different process that leaves the system in the
state Sigma the question now is what is the state of the system and to be clear
we're interested in the state of the system in isolation disregarding any other information that might exist about
which preparation was performed for example imagine that we don't have access to the coin or the
memory of whoever it was that performed the state preparation and the answer to that question is that it's simply the weighted average of the two density